there was like real pain and real
suffering in those old cartoons a
classic slapstick humors the interplay
between the Absurd and and suffering and
you know I was trying to explain this
and I told her how when I was a kid I
had a videotape of Looney Tunes about
six hours of it that we recorded on VHS
and of course you didn't know what VHS
had to explain that and uh we watched
that tape and we just watched it okay
that was what we did on Saturday
mornings we sat we watched the tape it
was the one tape and that's all we
watched we didn't have Netflix we
couldn't go and select the from a
thousand different shows you just put on
the tape and you watched it in the
morning someone said oh go grab the tape
and we grabbed because there was the
tape and we just watched the tape and
that's what we did